can we talk about the various phases of
giving notes like what would be the
first step
well notes first of all are
you know not just what you're getting
from producers
or getting from potential investors or
you know directors
when we say notes when hollywood says
notes it's anybody
giving you some point on something
you've written
that would make it better that would go
to make it better so
writing group gives you notes your
writing partner gives you notes
your anybody you've handed your script
to will give you notes that's the word
that hollywood uses and it's kind of
funny you know it's like a
a joke in the industry when anybody will
say anything and then someone will say i
have notes you know in other words
you know i could tweak that and make it
just better whatever it is right now so
mentors producers um finance people
sometimes give notes
directors the thing that changes then is
there that we have
there's kinds of notes and then there's
you know who's giving the notes and how
much attention you have to give to them
so
so um you know the kinds of notes uh say
we have something we call
line notes then you have broad story
notes
you have character notes you have you
know all things that have to do with the
content
and you know there might be that you get
some notes on you
as the the writer you know you're not
going there you're not
doing your research enough things like
that but but you know that
the the idea of knowing in every context
okay what kind of notes
am i going to be getting what should i
be expecting here
so that you go into a note session and
say
this is what i'm looking for and this is
what they should be providing me
and again in terms of setting yourself
up for failure
one of the things that happens is that
there's not that joint expectation so
the producer
has one thing that they're thinking to
talk about and the writer's going in
you know with their little notebook open
to get another thing and the
two things never they're trying to get
notes that maybe a mentor would give as
opposed to a producer
and uh that that can be a problem
sometimes
yeah so so but the phases of the notes
yeah so in almost every note
session it's really important to start
with the positive and start with what's
working about the project
because everything needs to be couched
in that and
so many note sessions are focused on the
negative or on what's not working that
sometimes
when you have when when a script is 90
working and you're focusing on that
10 that's not it's easy to lose
perspective
as a writer so it's really important if
you're if you're giving notes that
you're really focusing on
okay these are the 100 things that work
and then now we're going to focus on the
10 things that don't
and then also in every note session i
think it's extremely
important to say right up front what the
purpose of the notes
are so whether you're talking about
story and character whether you're at a
place where it's appropriate to talk
about story and character or whether
you're talking about little nitty-gritty
polished notes or typos those are very
different conversations
and are appropriate at different stages
of
development and the writer has to
control this a little bit because a lot
of times the producers
come into these things and you know
especially if they're busy you know
producers or
you know i'm saying producers or you
know somebody they they
they just start whipping things off you
know and it's like you know what you
have a typo on page 10 and oh
that that character just i hate that
character i never cared about the
character and
you know i don't know if this should be
a comedy or a thriller
or you have a shooting script and
they're like well maybe it should be a
comedy instead of a drama
yeah but you know but that idea of
throwing at the writer
like line notes you know like there's a
misspelling here i didn't think that
joke was funny and oh yeah that
character doesn't work okay
this is a note session that's out of
control so basically the writer should
come in and say okay this first
writing you know what i'm looking for
here in this um in this meeting
is notes about the story so
so i know that there's typos or i know
that stuff like there shouldn't be typos
but you know
i i know that there's other stuff but
let's just talk about
um the story and here's here's the arc
of the first story a story
what did you think about that story did
you did you and and to kind of really
keep the note giver on task
uh giving you the feedback that you need
and when we when we mentor writers we
typically start with
very broad story notes so we're talking
about characters what they want and what
they need and
what their how they're going to grow and
change
what their thrust is going to be in the
story
and then we talk about plot um and how
that's moving
things along and we pretty much stay
there and theme a little bit
but we pretty much stay there when we're
in the beginning stages of story we
don't go into dialogue and we don't go
into format
things like that because those are are
distractions to
the meat and potatoes of the story when
you're at a
at the beginning stages of developing a
project
now if you're two three drafts in it's
assumed that at that point you have your
story you have your characters
and you might still have one or two
notes about what
some a character does in particular in a
particular spot
which may not be in line with with um
you know the rest of the story there
might be something very specific there
um but that's when you give the notes
that are um
you know very you know nitpicky details
and when you're really getting into
just the the little things um
if you're giving really big broad story
in character notes on a third fourth
draft
um there there's a big that means that
there's a really big problem
with the with the skeleton with the core
of that script
and it probably needs to be completely
gutted and
and retooled yeah we find that
if you if you take care of the big
issues it's amazing how many the little
issues resolve themselves
and yet most writers are so resistant
sometimes to addressing the big issues
because the big issue sometimes is this
plot just doesn't work you know it just
doesn't work and that one is a no no
writer wants to hear because it means
completely replaced yeah reconceived and
so they do want to focus on
well did you like the little subplot
that takes place in the sardine factory
you know and it's like you know we don't
care about that right now we're telling
you that this character's
overall movement from you know a to
do b is not convincing and compelling
and that's what we need to go back to
and they have to get pulling the writer
you know back to
that but again the writer needs to be
managing this notes process in a lot of
ways you know and
everybody they meet with they need to to
know what they're looking for
and here's a red flag on notes by the
way too if if someone who's giving you
notes tries to tell you how to solve the
problems in your story
chances are you should you should uh nod
be nice and and
get out because the truth is the people
giving notes have read your script once
maybe twice
uh they're not invested in they don't
know what you've rejected they don't
know what you've tried all they can do
is tell you what isn't working for them
and that's the feedback the writer needs
as soon as the note giver starts to say
here's what you need to do
chances are they're defaulting that note
giver is defaulting to something they've
seen in a movie before
or they've seen in a story before and
they're trying to plug in a fix
that they you know like kind of some
all-purpose fix you know you need
you need 10 girls in a bikini in a car
to drive through you know we get an
explosion in here
yeah give a note once to a friend
can't we get a decapitation in before
the midpoint just to pick it up you know
yeah but um
but that that idea of trying to plug in
a fix
you know or anybody trying to do your
job and it's like that's not the note
giver's job the note giver's job is to
say
this is how this affected me this is
what
i got out of this not this is how you
should fix it and the writer really has
to resist someone else solving their
problem trying to do their job
let's say a writer is moving up the food
chain with a project and they know that
they're going to have five minutes
and this person may go right for the
jugular and they've got to compose
themselves
and they don't want to lose this whole
project what are some tips on keeping
calm
and and really keeping your defenses
back because maybe
whoever's going to deliver these notes
is a is a power player and they're not
going to be kind
what are some tips yeah well i mean
what's implied there is that it's a
high-stakes situation
and and now if this is somebody who can
literally green light your movie you
should definitely
take their note with uh you know
yeah exactly yeah yeah but if they're
not if it's just somebody giving their
their two cents but they're
higher up um if it's if it's a false
sense of of power then you know they
they've got to take that note just like
they would with anybody else
i think that you know the best thing is
to just tell yourself going in
this isn't me like this is my table this
is this is a table there's my script on
the table and i'm over here
and what we're doing is talking about
that thing we're not talking about me
as much as you can separate yourself
emotionally from your work and and you
know the best way to do that
write ten scripts write seven or eight
scripts right because the more
you do it the more you do the more it's
just another project and
you know but if you've got this one and
this is your life and it's your passion
then then you're so invested in it but
you know there's nothing like
being five or six scripts past that one
to to make you go back and say yeah i
can lose that
that thing i was so attached to you know
but um i think that one of the signs of
um
a writer that's difficult is that they
are way too attached to the project it's
way too much about them
which goes back to it's too personal and
that's too personal rights
yeah yeah you're not a professional